As a cold sort of statute like figure as
a person who,
um,
was he seen almost,
he's portrayed almost like a,
like a sherlock holmes character,
sort of all intellect and primarily
intellect and not a person of passion.
He was a deeply emotional person and
like lots of emotional people try to
hide that by appearing somewhat detached
and aloof.
So I think the notion of a,
of a cold and cerebral Jefferson is,
um,
is a misconception.
I mean he was almost irrational in some
ways,
in,
in passions about politics,
about people,
all kinds of things.
So that would be it getting rid of,
uh,
the,
the sort of Coal Jefferson,
there's this notion of him as someone
who's just sort of unfeeling,
detached person and there's just,
that's not right.
I mean,
he's a very much a man of sentiment and
feeling and that I think comes through
and what,
as you said,
with his attitudes about,
about,
um,
about wine and food and architecture and
all those kinds of things,
but he's not,
he's not all mind the head and heart.
The famous letter that he writes to
Maria,
Maria cosway.
Um,
and a lot of people assumed,
well,
the headwinds because that's what
Jefferson is,
but I don't,
I don't think that that's true.